[music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this [music]
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. As an empowered individual, you do
have options available. We're honored to
continue
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials [music]
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics [music] guiding us with the
best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health, Dr. Joel Wallach.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take
Hello, everybody. Let's go ahead and
open up that waiting room and let the
people into our live Zoom. Yes, folks,
we are live. Thank you so much for
waiting and coming and being on here
with us on Daily with Doc. Um, it is
exciting to have so many people in the
waiting room. So, as they're coming in,
I just want to invite those that are
watching the live stream.
If you are watching us live or even a
repeat
of any of our programs and you'd like to
join us, you may do so by going to
dailywithdoczoom.com
Monday through Friday from 12:00 to 1:00
p.m. Pacific time. So, again, that's
dailywithdoczoom.com.
Now, we are a resource for an amazing
community. And with this community, we
have people that are health coaches,
certified holistic health coaches,
health advocates, practitioners,
people who just love people and want to
make sure that they have the information
and opportunity to go from just barely
surviving to thriving, or even those
athletes that think they're on top of
the world. We want to keep them on top.
And in order to do that, it does require
intentional supplementation because that
sweat is just not water that they're
sweating out. It is a soup of minerals
that the body really needs to hold on
to. So, if you're sweating them out, you
got to be intentional about putting them
back in. And And that is part of the
core of our foundation in what we
recommend people do.
Now, this program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com,
where we have on our website
past shows, articles, good foods, bad
foods list. So, people that are wanting
to know, "Okay, what can I eat? What
should I stay away from?" You've got a
simple list there that makes it easy to
to print out or save and be able to
utilize each and every day because,
folks,
it is even includes the reasons why you
want to avoid or add them into your
diet.
All right?
Now, all of our information is based on
study and research, over 60 years
that have been put into what we do on
this show.
Now, the research is first hand from the
man himself. It also includes that of
other people, absolutely. But when it
comes to the foundation of nutrition, I
can't think of a better person to be
able to lead this journey, this crusade
to save humanity, than the doctor that
started this whole program with us. And
today we have him. I know we had some
technical difficulties yesterday, so we
are able to watch an incredible part one
of somebody needs to go to jail. So much
information that was shared there. So, I
hope that you can
really
listen.
Not just hear, not just let it play in
the background,
but really pay attention to what is
being said because it could save your
life or the life of others. Now, this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician, nor is
it meant to treat, diagnose, or cure any
disease. But folks, when you give the
body what it is starving for, the body
can do some amazing things. It is
continually regenerating cells. So, if
it's getting the nutrition that it needs
to create healthy cells,
then the body has no other way to go
than become healthier.
But if you're not not giving the body
what it needs and
you're giving it all these processed
foods that are empty of nutrition or
high sugar, high carbohydrate foods that
affect the body in a negative way,
including
inflammation. And then fried foods. Oh
my goodness, so many things that are
fried that are causing damage within the
body. Even if it's a good food and it's
cooked the wrong way,
it does damage within the body.
So, we want to make sure that people are
aware.
And if there are no questions about what
is causing their disease within their
body.
Now, because we are a resource to an
amazing community,
if there was somebody that that shared
this program with you, make sure that
you get back with them. If you have any
questions at all about anything you hear
on today's program, they are your point
of contact. So, get back with them.
Now, if you have never spoken to anybody
or you have never tried any of the
recommendations that are shared on this
program, you are more than welcome to
give us a call at 855-949-3377.
I do have a team of certified holistic
health coaches manning that phone line.
Or you can email us at
questions@dailywithdoc.com.
That's also the email if you have
questions that you'd like to hear
answers from Dr. Joel Wallach or
Pharmacist Ben Fuchs or Dr. Taylor
Mitchell or Dr. Laura Denison or Cara
Ringland naturopath or myself or any of
our coaches,
questions@dailywithdoc.com.
Okay?
So, without further ado,
you know, we were talking about the
foods that you should eat, even if
they're good things that are cooked the
wrong way.
Well, we get the question a lot about
kidney stones and gallstones.
So, that's what we're going to be
talking about today.
And to talk with that, just to to
communicate with us and share with us
what those two different stones are, how
they different, what causes them,
what we can do to get rid of them
because they are very painful and cause
a lot of discomfort and havoc within the
body.
We have the one and only, the doctor who
has started this all, the doctor who
worked his way through
veterinary school in a pathology lab
writing papers, doing the research,
finding things that
even toxins
that were polluting an environment of a
herd of sheep, a flock of sheep, rather.
Sorry.
And 500 of them died overnight.
He, at a young age, found the cause.
Found not just the the the cause of
death, but the cause of the cause of
death.
And the source of that cause.
And that's what he has been doing on so
many different levels, not just with
with animals. I mean, he's done
autopsies on over 452 different species.
Humans
are one of those species with thousands
of autopsies on humans as well.
So, help me welcome to the screen Dr.
Joel Wallach,
naturopath
doctor, doctor of naturopathic medicine,
licensed in California and Oregon.
California being one of the hardest ones
to become licensed in.
He is
also has three post doctorates and I'm
kind of starting at the back going wrong
way. Three post doctorates in pathology,
a doctor of veterinary medicine, a
bachelor of science in agriculture
studying plant and soil sciences.
So, Dr. Joel Wallach, welcome to Daily
with Doc. Thank you so much for being
here. I know Friday is not your normal
day with us, but I appreciate that you
are available to us to help us spread
the message of
what, when, why, and where
when it comes to these stones that
happen within the body. So, welcome,
Doc.
Well, thank you. Thank you. And thank
you, team, for everybody being here.
It's a real pleasure to be with us, the
team, which is our family.
And I can't thank everybody enough for
all the good things you do to get the
information out there.
Uh two things, as you pointed out,
Rebecca,
that um
gallstones,
which are in the gallbladder,
and then also
kidney stones, which are in the kidney,
are extremely common.
And of course, doctors, they want to put
[clears throat] you on dialysis and take
take your kidneys out and all that kind
of stuff.
And
they want to um
uh
take your gallbladder out and maybe even
remove part of or all of your liver and
so on. And
all this is all going the wrong
direction.
Okay?
And so, this is why we came up with so
many books. In fact, 2 days ago, we sold
200 copies of the book Dead Doctors
Don't Lie.
200 copies in 1 day.
Dead Doctors Don't Lie.
It goes into
>> 200 copies of this book?
Oh.
In which language?
I don't know. It's in 25 languages.
Well, I know the recording is in How
many sold How many sold 200 of?
Couple of days ago.
>> it English? English. English.
All right, fantastic. So, this available
is in is available in English and
Spanish,
easily available.
So, make sure that you get your copy of
Dead Doctors Don't Lie. You can find
that at drjwallach.com.
That is drjwallach.com.
Yeah. And of course, that's our biggest
selling book. We've sold over what, 300
million copies?
You're right up there, Doc.
Yeah, I know the lecture has over 400
million.
Yeah. Of the same name. And
it's the most listened to nutrition
lecture.
Dead Doctors Don't Lie.
>> it is. Right.
Okay? So, all this is related to
many, many different health issues and
diseases
and um
viruses, bacteria, fungus, and yeast.
And so, we we have a lot of experience
with this stuff.
So, here we go.
First thing you have to do,
uh if you have in your family uh
kidney stones
and um
>> Let's see here. Also,
>> let's see here, also
uh gallbladder stones.
>> uh gallbladder stones also, Gallstones.
Okay? okay?
And so, it's one of those things where
these are not genetic. Well, the whole
family has them.
Okay, well, they're all eating the same
recipe the grandma gave them, okay?
That's why they all have it. It's not a
genetic thing, but they're all eating
the same recipe, even though they're 50
mi apart or 200 mi apart. If they're
eating the same recipe, they're in
trouble, okay? So, none of the bad
foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
rye, no rice, no oats, no buckwheat, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks, even the
diet one's got to go. Carbonation
neutralizes stomach acids, so you cannot
digest food or absorb minerals. Very,
very important stuff.
And um
as you see, we have 25 best-selling
books. The newest one is the Metabolic
Syndrome,
okay?
It um
Found this on the web for 25
best-selling books. The newest one is
Metabolic Syndrome. Check it out.
I should turn this off.
Yeah, go ahead and and just or even just
turn the volume down, Doc.
So, Dr. Wallach was mentioning the
Metabolic Syndrome, which is one of the
newest books that I was able to and
honored to be able to help him put
together. Uh the Metabolic Syndrome.
And it goes over the different diseases
that are
that are part of that cluster of
diseases that they call the Metabolic
Syndrome. And like he said, it is not
genetic. Not genetic. Yeah, well, the
Metabolic Syndrome, okay, is featured by
abdominal obesity,
big fat belly,
type 2 diabetes, and hypertension, high
blood pressure. Those three things
together are found
in 30% of American adults in America.
30%, 1/3 American adults have the
Metabolic Syndrome. And then, there's 50
other diseases that won't kill you, you
know, like reddish skin and hair falling
out and that kind of stuff are also in
this book. And it's uh 40 pages. It's 40
pages. It's one of our soft uh cover
books. It's 40 pages. Okay? And so, this
can add many, many healthy years to your
life. And you know, we deal with people
who
have um they're 100 lb overweight, 200
lb overweight, 300 lb overweight, 400 lb
overweight, 500 lb overweight. These are
real people, okay? And so, we get them
going on the right uh
right nutrition, right diet, supplement
program, and usually within um 90 days,
they're totally different, normal
person. So, we have a lot of experience
with this. And so, um getting these
books is a is a easy way for the average
person. If you can read the fifth grade
reading level, you can do it, okay?
And uh
each of the cranial nerves,
there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves in
the spinal cord. Um
in the book, "It's All in Your Head",
there's 30 pages in that book. Each
chapter, okay?
Each chapter, um and there's 12
chapters,
okay? And it and each chapter represents
one of the cranial nerves, okay? And so,
uh when you have a this is what doctors
they love people with osteoporosis of
the skull.
And osteoporosis of the skull
uh affects the spinal cord. It affects
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves. And in
this book,
my favorite book,
"It's All in Your Head",
top picture's that of a normal skull.
They've taken the top part of the skull
off and looking down on the
um brain, you see the skull, normal
skulls are quite a bit thick. The bottom
skull, they've taken the top of the
brain skull off looking down on the
brain, and the the skull's an inch and a
half to 2 in thick. Well, the the skull,
okay? It tends
>> Just stand, Doc. Can hear you clearly.
Okay, thank you.
The skull that's osteoporosis
is squeezing those 12 pairs of cranial
nerves. And you know, there's 12
different types of specialties,
and one of which goes with each of the
pair of nerves. And each chapter in this
book represents one of these cranial
nerves. And the odds are you won't need
to have your head amputated, and you
won't need to have your nerves cut out,
and your hearing mechanism cut out, and
so forth. You'll be deaf, and and so
forth. This is all
reversible once you know what the truth
is about osteoporosis of the skull,
okay?
And then, of course, for the spinal
cord, goes into a lot of things south of
the neck, okay? All of these nerves
coming out of of the brain,
okay? And of course, we have this this
CD that goes along with the book.
Okay, now,
Oh, Doc, before you go any farther, you
were talking about the the nerves and
I don't know how many people realize the
vagus nerve
is attached to their ears,
their lungs, their heart, their
intestines, their stomach.
Their liver. Their legs.
Their reproductive organs, you know.
It's the it's the
>> so if you've got
>> spinal cord.
>> if you've got something going on up here
squeezing and preventing those signals
from going through
or causing damage to any of the the
nerves,
you're going to have some problems. And
it when I hear somebody saying, "Oh, I
had my the my nerve endings burned." And
I'm like, "Oh my word."
Yeah, and of course each chapter in here
represents one cranial nerve. So,
there's 12 chapters and then of course
there's there's the spinal cord.
12 pairs of cranial nerves and the
spinal cord. When they get squeezed,
you can have over there's over 50
different diseases. Doctors love
osteoporosis of the skull.
They won't tell you you have
osteoporosis of the skull. They'll say,
"Oh, you you're
uh 10th cranial nerve, your vagus nerve
vagus nerve is in trouble. So, we have
to remove several of the branches and
blah blah blah blah blah for the pain to
go away."
>> Well, they don't even tell Doc, they
don't even tell you about the vagus
nerve.
They work at where you feel the pain.
Mhm.
Not upstream and what's actually causing
the pain.
So, again folks, you can get Dr.
Wallach's books at drjwallach.com.
drjwallach.com.
And Dr. Wall all of his publications
are there. So, Doc, let's go back to
kidney stones and gallstones.
Are they the same? It's just different
in in the different organ?
Mhm. Well, the [clears throat] principle
is the same.
When you have for instance
uh kidney stones,
okay?
This is calcium that's been removed from
the from the um bones of your legs and
your pelvis and your ribs and your um
uh so forth, your skull.
And
the calcium is trying to be preserved.
Your kidneys are trying to keep the
calcium from going out of the body and
they collect um in the urinary bladder,
they collect they collect in the
um kidneys.
And you know, they get bigger than a
pea, they begin to cause pain and block
um blood flow, block flow of urine.
And doctors want to remove your kidneys
and put you on dialysis and all this
kind of stuff.
And so, they're going the wrong
direction.
And of course
>> So, why Doc,
why would
why would calcium be pulled out of the
bones? Isn't that where we want the
calcium to be?
Yes. Well, when you are not getting
enough calcium coming in,
you need calcium in your heart, you need
calcium in your liver, you need calcium
in your lungs, you need calcium in your
muscles, you need calcium in your
tendons and ligaments, you need calcium
in your brain.
You need calcium in your blood. And so,
if you're not taking in enough calcium
in your diet through supplementation or
eating properly or both,
um your body starts pulling calcium out
of your bones to supply the calcium to
all these other places.
And so, when you get when you get kidney
stones, this is telling you that you
have terrible
osteoporosis.
You don't have too much calcium, you
don't have enough calcium.
And your body is robbing the calcium
which left out of your bones to try and
support your need for calcium.
Okay. So, that that totally I think
explains a lot for people, especially
those that already have arthritis or
osteoporosis or anything going on with
their bones
and kidney stones.
Or they do blood work and the doctor
says you have too much calcium in your
blood. You got to stop eating milk or
drinking milk, eating cheese and taking
calcium supplements. That's the opposite
of what they should be doing. Isn't that
>> correct.
That is correct. The those instructions
are the opposite of what should be done.
Okay, so let's move on to the
gallbladder.
What is the cause What is What are
gallstones made up of? Well, gallstones
Yeah, well gallstones are made up out of
the essential fatty acids, okay? We have
the EFA Plus's.
Okay? But but those are good. Yeah, I
take three of those three times a day.
I take three three times a day the EFA
EFA Plus's.
And
>> [clears throat]
>> this provides the raw materials
to make the covering of your nerves.
Okay? Your brain, your myelin
in your brain and spinal cord.
>> you're talking cholesterol? Okay. Which
is good.
Also, um
it it helps you with
uh, sex hormones.
Okay, you need the
cholesterol
to make sex hormones, both male and
female.
And so, if they're putting you on
a cholesterol
reduced diet and then putting on
medication to
really knock down your cholesterol
levels in your blood and your tissues,
you're going to have
20 different doctors
You're going to have problems.
>> sending their kids to college based on
your insurance payments to them.
Right. So, okay, if
we need EFAs, essential fatty acids,
yes. We need that good cholesterol.
Why would cholesterol be building up as
stones in the gallbladder?
Okay, well, when this when it circulate
um, cholesterol,
okay, and you get to a certain level,
it's it's pulled out of the circulation
into the gallbladder.
And
um, what should I say?
It um, it starts accumulating and it
gets dehydrated, and so it forms these
pea-like
size stones in the gallbladder.
And so, for a long time, I don't know,
over 100 years or more,
um, doctors have been making a living
just removing people's gallbladders cuz
they had two or three gallstones in
there which were painful.
And so, they
>> Right. So, they would remove they would
remove their gallbladder because they
had gallstones. And really, they didn't
have to remove their gallbladder. All
they had to do was take all the 90
essential nutrients including
want to take the
um,
EFAs,
okay, essential fatty acids, and you
want to take the
um,
How about the ultimate enzymes?
Oh, well, ultimate enzymes,
okay, EFA Plus. You want the ultimate
enzymes, of course, help digestion.
Mhm.
So, okay,
there's good cholesterol, there's bad
cholesterol.
The bad cholesterol is
I mean, sugar converts to
um, or contributes to bad cholesterol.
Fried foods
and those bottled oils contribute to the
bad cholesterol. That is correct.
>> Is that the cholesterol that's building
up in the gallbladder that's causing
issues? That's correct.
>> And it
And is it just a digestive issue as
well?
Well, it's not just a digestive issue.
It is a digestive issue, but it also
impacts the brain and spinal cord cuz
85% of your brain mass and your spinal
cord mass is cholesterol. It's called
myelin. It's the white matter of the
brain and the spinal cord.
And so, when you're not getting all the
right foods and all the right cofactors,
it it shows up wherever you have large
amounts of these things. Okay, the
ovaries, the testicles, they all get hit
with
um,
what should I say? Improper usage
of this, okay? Cholesterol is one of
your best friends.
Okay, make sex hormones, okay?
Um,
and also is 85% of your brain and spinal
cord.
You don't want to be taking drugs to
reduce your cholesterol. You want to be
eating properly so you don't damage the
cholesterol.
Right.
>> [snorts]
>> All right, thank you so much for that,
Dr. Wallach. Um,
as we get a lot of questions about
kidney stones, a lot of questions about
gallstones, and and I've even heard of
people that have had their gallbladder
removed and they're still getting stones
that are in that duct.
Well, what will happen is uh, when you
remove the gallbladder, there's still
the tubes in the liver, okay, moving
bile around,
okay, to get the bile out into the
intestines to help you absorb essential
fatty acids and fat-soluble vitamins and
and so forth.
And you can still get terrible pain, you
can still get
gallstones
in your liver. They don't necessarily
have to be in the gallbladder.
And a lot of people don't realize that.
So, it's not just a gallbladder thing,
but those stones can be also in the
liver.
Well, Dr. Wallach, we
we have some hands up. Are you ready to
take some questions?
Yes, ma'am.
All right. Just as a reminder, folks, if
you were invited to this program by
somebody specific, make sure that you
get back with them. If you have a
question for Dr. Wallach
get his advice on what you can do
nutritionally to address some of the
symptoms that you are experiencing, then
raise your hand. If you're out on any of
the different platforms and you have a
way of commenting, you can absolutely
comment and put those questions up as we
do have people on our team that are
fielding those questions and something
that just came in and I I want to I want
to read this doc off of Rumble.
Um one of our amazing followers says,
"Thanks Becca for sending me the reruns.
Have been having computer
issues and haven't been able to listen
to them so much, but they are in my
favorites. I thank you, Becca." Well,
those those reruns being sent,
that's because of AJ. Um so, I want to
make sure credit is going where it needs
to. He said that he had found a
testimonial of an older lady about
arthritis being all gone
um and
says
that the
these kind of videos make us avid
listeners. Okay, sometime I believe the
food industry along with a couple
different entities are making our foods
not so healthy and I'm going to say on
purpose and there's sure is a lot of
research showing that.
So, thank you, Dr. Wallach. He says Dr.
W, but Dr. Wallach, Becca, all the
coaches, etc. God bless. Keep teaching,
please. We are listening.
So, we just want to do a
a [clears throat] thank you everybody
for listening because we know that we
are touching a lot of individuals and
helping them to obtain a better health
journey. So, let's go to Marilyn.
Marilyn,
what question do you have for Dr.
Wallach today? Go ahead and unmute
yourself. Yeah, I have two.
Uh the first one, plaque.
>> right. Some people say plaque can just
be calcium only. Is that possible?
I'm sorry, say that again. Can calcium
build up be just I mean, can plaque be
just calcium build up or is it always
cholesterol, fatty substances,
all of that?
>> Uh well,
elevated calcium
>> [clears throat]
>> will cause other things to happen.
And so, you get this collection
of
um a bad environment,
the um calcium begins to deposit in
unusual places.
Okay, it could be muscle, it could be
brain, it could be arteries, uh
walls of arteries and veins and so.
And begins to
fill up the
matter of those arteries and veins. And
so, your blood pressure starts going up.
And then,
you start getting abdominal obesity
and you get type 2 diabetes. You also
have now what?
Oh, you have the metabolic syndrome.
And 1/3
1/3 of Americans adults, both male and
female, have the metabolic syndrome. All
these things are going wrong in them
because they're not taking supplements.
They're just eating what their family
ate many years ago. But they may have
been a different place. They may have
been 200 miles away. They may have been
1,000 miles away. And their parents may
have been getting
oh, let's say
um they may have been getting 50, 60, 70
minerals in their food where they came
from, the land flowing with milk and
honey.
And you're getting food
in a local
from local grocery stores they get it
from a garden that only has three
minerals in it.
I'm eating the same exact recipe my mom
and dad ate and they didn't have these
problems.
Well, that's because they were getting
50 minerals and you're only getting
three.
So, the calcium contributes to the
gallstones and kidney stones?
Calcium deficiency.
Calcium deficiency contributes to a lot
of things.
Cuz every organ in the body, every
tissue in the body requires calcium.
So, if your brain, your liver, your
heart, your lungs,
your intestines, your your stomach, your
muscles,
uh your kidneys,
uh
okay?
Uh
it's what I say, your skin.
And so, this these nutrients were
put on us by the good Lord.
And when you look at all mammals, when
you look at all mammals, whether they're
whales
or buffalo
or
antelope or deer
or rats or rabbits or
raccoons, cows, sheep,
dogs, cats,
they require all these nutrients, too.
Now, in the animals, we don't have
health insurance. You notice we don't
have health insurance for animals like
we do people?
And so, most people are not going to pay
$100 a month for health insurance for
their puppy dog.
So, that's why we came out with the
ArthryDex
um supplement program for dogs and cats
and rabbits and so forth,
monkeys and so on.
And
um it covers a lot of territory.
Okay?
Uh you have to appreciate when a coyote
uh kills a rabbit, they don't just eat
the meat.
They eat the liver.
This rabbit has been accumulating
minerals for some time in the in the
liver. So, they eat the liver, they eat
the heart, they eat the muscles, they
eat the tendons and ligaments,
and the skin.
And so, they're getting a lot of
different tissues. They're not just
getting a steak just made out of red
meat.
Okay. One One other question. I have a
woman uh wrote into the show, so I don't
have any measurements on her. She just
says she has extreme itching.
Uh her face, she has it's extreme
psoriasis. It's like she has sheets of
skin peeling off her face.
Is she lacking essential fatty acids?
Kind of correlating with all of this
that we're talking about.
>> you know how much she weighs? I don't
have any other measurements. She just
>> Okay. Well, let's go let's go by 100 lb.
Okay. For every 100 lb, she eats one
healthy brain and heart pack.
Okay? Per month. Okay?
Take a half a dose twice a day if she
weighs 100 lb. If she weighs 140 lb or
more, get two healthy brain and heart
packs. Take a full dose at breakfast,
full dose at dinner time.
Then,
um she needs to get
um
two or three bottles of the hair, skin,
and nails.
Take three of those at breakfast, lunch,
and dinner. That's going to give her
skin
what it needs to be happy and healthy,
but she also needs
the
uh EFA Plus, EFA Plus,
which goes into the essential fatty
acids that are necessary for for good uh
skin
and muscle and tendon ligament health
and bone marrow health to make red blood
cells and that kind of stuff.
And so, you know, you go back
several hundred years ago when when
people were transferring
from
people who just went on herbs from the
local herbalist and so forth to
um going with the medical doctors and so
on.
And
this transition caused an enormous
amount of new diseases nobody ever seen
before.
Okay? Because
for
200,000, in some cases 300,000 years,
okay? The Neanderthals, which were the
cavemen,
controlled the earth for over 200 to
300,000 years. The Neanderthals, the
cavemen, controlled the earth.
Now, the interesting thing about them,
when they killed an animal,
they ate everything.
The heart, the liver, the brain, the
skin, but also
also,
they put wood ashes
from their
heating fires, their cooking fires, and
so forth, they put the wood ashes into
their gardens for fertilizer cuz they
saw when you threw
just to get rid of them, they would
throw the wood ashes into the gardens
and in the places where they threw the
wood ashes in, the plants flourished and
they got more yield and so forth. So,
everybody started putting wood ashes
into their gardens.
And wood ashes were their source of
minerals.
Okay?
And then also,
coal ashes.
September 4th,
September 4th, 1882,
every big city in the world flipped a
switch and went to electricity. Suddenly
now, there's no more wood ashes, no more
coal ashes to supply to supply our
minerals. And suddenly now, we're
getting all these diseases that were due
to mineral deficiencies
that nobody ever seen before.
And doctors said, "Oh, it's a genetic
thing."
Genetics are whether you're a boy or a
girl. Genetics are whether you have
black skin or white skin, or you're
oriental. Uh genetics, what color hair
you have,
what color your eyes are. That's it.
There are no
caused by bad genes.
Yeah, so you're saying there's genetic
traits,
but there are no genetic diseases. Two
totally different things.
Well, there's genetic traits for eye
color and skin color. There's three or
four things. Just three or four things,
that's it.
But everything the doctors don't know,
they say, "Oh, it's a genetic thing."
Well, no.
Uh it it
whether you're a boy or a girl is not a
genetic thing.
It's a nutritional thing.
Okay? That's determined when you were an
embryo in your mother's
uterus, the early stages of pregnancy.
And this is why they're having all this
confusion with
with um boys who think they're girls and
girls who think they're boys and so
forth. Cuz they're getting confused in
the early stages of pregnancy
by not having the right nutrients in the
right places when those parts of the
brains were formed.
Right. Now, going back to this woman,
Dr. Wallach, where her skin is peeling,
I've seen the pictures. Her skin gets
really bright red
and then the skin is just it's it's like
kind of like how a snake sheds its skin.
What would you recommend for somebody
that is
I'm of course they want to go gluten
free
but there must be a digestive issue with
a bunch of nutrient deficiencies.
What would you recommend?
Okay, well
like I said they got to get rid of all
the bad stuff. No fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat, no rye, no oats, no buckwheat, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks. You know
that one's got to go.
They've got to
get on the 90 essential nutrients the
healthy brain and heart pack appropriate
for body weight.
They need to
um
we're talking about skin now.
Yes, we're talking about the skin
peeling off.
>> the and the again the hair, skin, and
nails take three of those minimum
three times a day, three breakfast,
three lunch, three dinner time. They're
little bottles so they'll be
um two to three bottles a month
depending on their body weight of the
hair skin
>> Probably three.
And then
and they're also going to need the gluco
gel.
Gluco gel cuz hair is kind of related to
skin. It's uh you know has to do with
with um skin issues.
>> Connective tissue?
Connective tissues? Yeah. So we need we
need the gluco gel
and I'm the one that created gluco gel
for Theo Rath life. I created gluco gel
because people were for thousands of
years, tens of thousands of years, for
100,000 years people were were um
um boiling bones at night and then
drinking the bone broth the next day and
getting
the collagen
which kept their bones good
300,000 years ago. Now they didn't know
all the chemistry and everything but
they knew when they when they drank that
boiled
um
bones
the next day
the people who did that didn't get bone
problems.
Right.
How about collagen Dr. Wallach? I know
you mentioned the gluco gel which is a
form of collagen. We've got the collagen
peptides that has five different types
of collagen in it. Would that be
beneficial as well?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
And um
it's one of those things where
um they
and the collagen peptides they've kind
of pre-digested it for you so it's easy
to absorb so you won't lose any
>> does. Yeah.
>> at the other end.
>> It also includes enzymes which a lot of
collagens don't. It includes the enzymes
that help break down that collagen so
the body can actually utilize it and
absorb it.
Is there anything Can I ask one thing?
Is there anything she can apply
topically cuz it's so bad on her face
right now? She feels real depressed.
Well again
we have a liquid gluco gel
which you can drink or put on your skin.
>> Yeah, don't put on your I would I
wouldn't put it on your skin doc. It's
sticky.
It's sticky.
Well then don't ask about what you can
put on your skin.
Okay. So I would do colloidal silver
just in case that there's any type of
infection going on topically
um for that.
Marilyn then also take some internally
like Dr. Wallach says
as a dropper on each side of the mouth
um
Under the tongue.
Absolutely.
So and
in the Youngevity skin care line
there is a collagen serum
and also hyaluronic acid serum. And
folks, you hear acid and you get scared.
No, no, no, no. This helps with
exfoliating the skin and helping to keep
this skin healthy. So those would be two
topical things Marilyn that I would
recommend for her.
Okay? And there's there's also the
Trinity lotion which has a beta glucan
in it which is very beneficial for
helping to overcome um situations like
that and
make the hands skin healthier again.
That's the Trinity lotion.
Yeah. And also
um
I like also for the skin and the brain
and the spinal cord and the muscles and
so forth and the liver and the heart
the chewable
I-26. I-26.
Well and that's going to help most of
all that's going to help with her
digestive system Dr. Wallach. So if
there's things going on in the digestive
system that I-26 is so beneficial for
that. So I'm glad you remembered that.
And it's also the raw materials
to rebuild the brain and the spinal
cord.
It's not only digestive Absolutely. It's
actually
what the white matter of the brain and
spinal cord is made out of is in those
tubules.
All right. Thank you so much, Dr.
Wallach. Now, we have Thomas that
wrote in and this is going back to
kidney stones. Says diabetics and kidney
stones. What about the increased effect
or higher probability of kidney stones
caused by medication that diabetics use
to control their A1C readings, whether
it's insulin or or an oral, both of
which have been studied and found to
have higher incidence like 67%
more of kidney stones. Is it just the
medication or is it a combination of the
medication and nutritional deficiency?
We have to appreciate that both those
diseases
the kidney stones and diabetes are
caused by nutritional deficiencies.
Rarely is a person deficient in one
nutrient. If you're deficient in a
nutrient, you could be deficient in the
90 essential nutrients, you could be a
deficient in 50 of them.
This is this Yeah, places on Earth where
people only live to be 25.
Okay, compared to where people are
getting all these minerals from the
mountains, the glacial milk, they're
getting
um
75 to 100 minerals
and they live to be 125
without doctors.
Without doctors. Absolutely, without
that interference.
Well, doc We've got several questions
with hands coming up and also messages
coming in at me. So, let's go to a man.
Is it
Mario? So, forgive me. Go ahead and
unmute yourself.
Autome?
Can you Yes. Yes.
Um
First What question do you have for doc?
Well, first I want to thank Dr. Wallach
because he's he changed our lives. Uh
but my question is
um
I have a male. He's 35 37 years old and
175 lbs
and he he born with small kidneys
and he didn't have any problems until he
get adult.
He's he's eating dialysis.
And
I give him the health health and brain
uh
uh pack
and also the
ultimate
daily classic.
And he's taking that, but would you
recommend something else? Uh is is
And I know two more people. They they
born with a small kidneys. Is Okay, if
they're born with
small kidneys, yeah, they need need need
the 90 essential nutrients and have the
brain and heart pack. And of course,
it's really a good idea to you you did
you did the correct thing. You did the
right thing.
Okay.
By putting him on the ultimate daily
classic that helps get the blood moving
through the arteries and veins in the
kidneys even if they're blocked with
cholesterol.
Okay.
And so
doctors want to remove your kidneys and
put you on dialysis. You have to come in
every couple of weeks and go go on
dialysis. Okay, to clean your blood.
Get get on
the
ultimate daily classic. Save your
kidneys so you don't get them surgically
removed by the doctor. Okay.
And so there's all kinds of stuff. I
mean, we deal
with over 600 different diseases.
We have 2500 products. We have 2,500
products. We deal with over 600
different diseases.
And this is why we have 25 different
books.
And I urge people you know, get the
basic ones. Get Hell's Kitchen. Go to
chapter 14 first. Read Hell's Kitchen.
Okay.
And then get the book Immortality. You
want to live to be a long time a long
life, get the book Immortality. Go to
chapter 11 first.
Okay.
The truth about nutrition.
You have to read this book, The Truth
About Nutrition, so you understand
what nutrition means.
Okay.
And so why do you have to take
supplements? Well, my doctor said I
could just eat well and get everything I
need. You need a new doctor.
You cannot.
Cuz even even the
um
okay, even when you're when you're
making um
your
um
uh
supplements, okay
by boiling
bones and so forth, kind of doing a
a bone broth thing.
Okay.
If you're not able to absorb that
it's coming out the the other end. Okay.
So, you really need to make sure
that you're
um doing all these things properly
so you can absorb the the minerals.
And you can you can absorb some minerals
just by rubbing them on your skin.
Okay.
But you want to to put them on your
skin, you want to take them orally.
And again, we have the ultimate EFAs,
prevents
and reduces the risk of um
the
uh
gallstones
>> A lot.
Yeah, the EFA pluses.
Okay, and then of course the
um
kidney stones, you want to get them on
the Osteo-fx
and the Cal Toddy. In addition to the
Cal Toddy and Osteo-fx, get them on
those elevated calcium products.
But but he's got too much calcium. No,
he's he's got the calcium in the wrong
place.
So you need more calcium and this the
um
to Okay,
so the small kidneys
they can work normal? Oh, yeah,
absolutely. They work normal and they no
matter if they small. If even if they're
half the normal size, they will still
work perfectly. Okay. Okay, that's what
I wanted to know because this man is a
maybe because I have my kidneys too
small, maybe I'm going to have dialysis
for all my life.
>> been talking. He's been talking to my
doctor.
Okay. Thank you very much, doctor, for
>> Yeah, keep us informed. Let us know how
these things go because you're going to
have great stories. Okay, thank you. I
will. God bless. Thank you.
All right, thank you. Great question.
And Dr. Wallach, Rosie has a question.
We've got a female, 200 lb, 5'3,
55 years old with a fatty liver.
So there is some blood pressure issues,
there are and some sugar issues. Uh what
causes fatty liver and what can be done
to change that? I know the liver itself
can regenerate, but we got to give it
the right ingredients.
Well,
how many ingredients does a liver need?
90. Well, there you go.
If the liver is only getting three
or five, you're going to get all kinds
of problems with the liver. You get
liver cirrhosis, scar tissue in the
liver,
um you get um blood clots in the liver,
um you get the arteries and veins uh in
the liver getting plugged.
Okay? And so
the liver is kind of like the brain. The
brain goes through all those things,
too, when you don't have enough
nutrition.
Okay?
And so you don't want to have a liver
transplant. You don't want to have a
brain transplant. You don't want to have
a kidney transplant. Okay?
And so
um every family should have these books.
Every family should have these nutrients
and if you, you know,
uh sign up as a member in the team,
guess what?
You'll pay the wholesale prices. You
won't pay the retail prices. And if you
get two or three or four or five people
in your family sponsored underneath you,
guess what? You'll get a check from us
every month and you can use that check
to buy more vitamins and minerals to
give your mom and dad and your kids and
so forth or sell them, whatever you want
to do. It's one of those things where
uh the system is set up to maximize the
benefit that we can provide to humanity,
no matter where you are at on Earth, no
matter where you fall in your family.
So doc
with fatty liver, is it truly fat that's
building up on the liver?
Fat is building up in the cells of the
liver cuz they don't have all the right
nutrients
to
have the liver be able to eat the the
fat
and burn the fat.
Okay, so what would you recommend
uh for a targeted nutrition uh for the
body as a whole and then the secret
sauces for fatty liver?
Okay, the healthy brain and heart pack.
Um the secret sauce
for the liver would be the
uh let's see here.
The EFA pluses.
>> it the liver
EFA pluses? Okay.
And the the liver formula?
Well, the liver formula is good, but
also um the
uh let's see here.
The
um
the little the little pills for the
liver. Okay? That's the liver. Yeah, the
Pollen Burst liver formula. There you
go. Pollen Burst liver formula.
All right, and at so uh 200 lb, that
would be at least two twice a day
on the Pollen Burst liver formula. Well,
there you go.
All right, thank you so much, Dr.
Wallach. And next, let's go to Hattie.
Hattie, go ahead and unmute yourself.
We've only got about 10 minutes and
three hands up, doc. So
Hattie, can we hear you?
I see that she's unmuted, but I'm not
hearing her. Can you hear me, Becca?
Now I can. Go for it, Maya.
Good. Listen, hey Dr. Wallach, I just
got a call.
Young woman, she's 3 months pregnant.
This whole time she's been so uh
impacted. Can't go to the bathroom.
She's been to the ER twice, had some
enemas.
Still nothing.
So last night she said she took a whole
bunch almost a whole box of Dulcolax.
The laxative.
And so now and she and she managed to
go.
But now she's worried about
how all this laxative what's the impact
on the baby.
And what should she do to keep from
being impacted like this again?
Well, she needs to take the 90 essential
nutrients so early, right?
Yes.
>> then of course
the for the happiness of digestive
system, need the ultimate enzymes.
Okay? All of the enzymes.
And
stay away from all the bad foods.
And so this is kind of where you need to
start. Don't forget the 90 essential
nutrients.
Uh and of course
uh the liver, the intestines,
the digestive enzymes.
Um
And I-26.
I-26? So the So the laxatives won't have
an impact on the baby, right?
Well, the baby requires all these
nutrients to develop.
If the mother's not getting these
nutrients for her, she's going to have a
baby born with a birth defect
or multiple birth defects.
So doctor, question is is is the
the laxative that was taken and can that
have a negative effect on the baby
that's growing within? And Hattie, did
you say 2 months or 10 months? I heard
10.
>> the baby is 4 months.
4 months, okay.
Well, it's hard to say because again
when you're when you're taking uh the
you know, the um
enzymes to have a bowel movement, okay?
Um you're getting rid of nutrients as
well as getting a bowel movement.
Okay? And so there can be a loss of
nutrients to the level at which there
can be a birth defect caused by a lack
of nutrition.
So can the chemicals of this
over-the-counter laxative
it what should she do
to make sure it's not What she needs to
do is talk to her doctor
and find out what
what she needs to do.
Okay.
>> right.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Hattie. Thank you.
All right, and let's go right over to
Michelle. Michelle, go ahead and unmute
unmute yourself.
Great, thank you. And so I have a
27-year-old
um 6-foot woman
um 195 lb.
Um they diagnosed her with mast cell
activation syndrome, which all that
means is she has anaphylaxis from food
allergies.
So cleaning up the bad foods definitely
and um
so she's just coming into the program.
So what do you recommend?
Well, 195 lb she's got to get rid of all
the bad foods, no fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat, no rye, no barley, no oats, no
buckwheat, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. Even the diet ones got to go.
She needs two healthy brain and heart
packs a month, a full of those taking at
breakfast and dinner. She needs the
ultimate daily classic tablets, take
three at breakfast, three at dinner time
for blood flow
uh into all the tissues.
Um
Let's see here. Um she needs the I-26
so that her brain and spinal cord
are able to maintain themselves when
hurt for her to get the Xerafem.
Uh the girly
um tablets that help the ovaries make
estrogen and so forth, okay?
And um then of course we have the Cal
Toddy, we have the Osteo FX,
and we have the EFA Plus's.
You know, we've got
2,500
products.
Right. Okay.
All right, we'll get her started. Thank
you so much.
>> Hey, you're very welcome. Thank you.
Yeah, keep us informed.
Albert, go ahead and unmute yourself.
What question do you have for Dr.
>> just wanted to ask Dr. Wallach. Yes.
Hello, hello.
Yeah.
Doctor, what I want to ask is when
you're talking about the kidney stones
and the gallstones
um once they are formed how effectively
does wood nutrition help to dissolve it,
and can they be dissolved quite
efficiently with uh uh with the correct
nutrition?
Okay, a good diet coming from a bad diet
can stop the formation of kidney stones
and gallstones.
Okay? And here's where they need the 90
essential nutrients, they need the
uh ultimate enzymes, they need the
uh
let's see here, they need digestive
enzymes,
and
it's one of those things where
um
they need the again the 90 essential
nutrients, they need the Ultimate Daily
Classic tablets, so that the kidneys are
working properly,
and
uh it doesn't hurt to throw in
you know, we have these
uh
other nutrients, okay? Uh Rebound one of
our sports drinks. I love the Rebound
cuz it has so many vitamins and minerals
in it that you don't find normally in
food and you know, in average diet.
And so
the uh Rebound sports drink, it comes uh
30 of these sticks in a box.
Tear off one corner of this, pour it
into a bottle of water, and shake it up
real good. And I go through two of these
a day.
That's in addition to everything else. I
go through two of these a day.
Um
okay, the Rebound,
and that will give you energy, it will
give you raw materials
for your brain, your heart, your lungs,
your muscles, your digestion,
everything to work properly.
Thank you, doctor.
Bye, donkie. Uh alles van die beste. Tot
siens. Lekker ry.
Bye, donkie.
>> All right. And Dr. Wallach, I've got an
email that came in. It says, "Hi, I have
a family member diagnosed with prostate
cancer that has spread to the bone
marrow causing low red blood cells, low
hemoglobin, PSA currently at at 89.
Doctors want him to take a medication
that will affect the pituitary gland and
cause chemical castration."
Cancer doctor said that his testosterone
is what feeds the cancer, so they want
to lower testosterone, which is going to
cause him to be very tired. They said
the medications clean the cancer from
the bones. They've also been He's also
been diagnosed with A-fib. They said
it's related to the cancer and low red
blood count. This individual is 80 years
old, 6 ft and 200 lbs, and very active.
What Dr. Wallach, what what would you
recommend? I know we can't
touch on some of these things, but to
help support the body.
Well, yes, yes,
you said the word support the body here.
Get rid of all the bad stuff. Get rid of
all the interference. No fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat, no barley, no rye, no oats, no
buckwheat, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks,
no alcohol, you know, no wine, no
whiskey, no beer, none of that kind of
stuff.
Then
um
and you say weighs how much?
200 lbs. 200 lbs, okay. Two healthy
brain and heart Passion Fruit of the
Month, a full dose at breakfast, full
dose at dinner time.
And then also
I would go
uh again uh with the
um
with the uh support,
okay? Cuz if you give too much support,
the support goes to the cancer and
supports the cancer. Okay?
And so basically what I would do
is um
get something like the Cal Toddy, uh
>> And and I know you have Z Radical on
that side of the desk also, Dr. Wallach.
You have Z Radical, okay. With the
fucoidan, which if you look go to
pubmed.gov,
look up fucoidan and cancer, there's
lots of research that is in support of
using fucoidan. So that Z Radical
uh could be very beneficial in this
situation as well,
which um at his weight, he could have 4
oz twice a day.
And then how about the BTT tablets, Dr.
Wallach? They have a very high ORAC
rate, which is full of antioxidants that
support the body.
Which one are you talking about?
The Beyond Tangy Tangerine, the tablet
form. Mhm.
Yeah, BTT.
Yeah, BTT tablets. Would you recommend
that as well? Yeah, well, that will help
um
support immune system.
Very good. Good thinking.
All right, thank you so much for that.
>> [snorts]
>> Now, Dr. Wallach, we're at the top of
the hour. Do you have time for one more
question?
Or you got a good
>> go for one more. Let's go for one more.
All right, Ruth Ellen.
Thank you for raising your hand. What
question do you have for Doc today?
Okay, so on YouTube, we have Olga.
She's asking if a 12-week-old kitten
can be given bovine colostrum.
And then she
>> I didn't hear. She's looking away from
the camera when she was talking.
>> I'm reading. Um
Olga would like to know if a 12-week-old
kitten can be given bovine colostrum.
A 12-year-old
kitten?
>> week
12-week-old kitten
can it be given bovine colostrum?
Yes.
Okay.
And then she wants to know
what you think about using cocoa butter
for making chocolates and other things
like that.
It's fine. Cocoa's fine. I have In fact,
when we're done here, I'm going to go
eat a bunch of
cheese sticks
uh with um
uh some chocolate.
Perfect. Thank you so much, Dr. Wallach.
All right. We are at the top of the
hour, so Ruth Ellen, go ahead and stay
on and if our other co-host can join us
as well. Dr. Wallach, thank you so much
for being here with us on Daily with
Doc. We appreciate you, your knowledge,
and the time that you are continuing
even at 85.
Continuing.
>> thank you
for putting all this together. You know,
we had some difficulties yesterday, but
to thank you for putting everything
together here so that it works. So,
thank you, AJ.
I appreciate everybody.
And so, this is a a wonderful team
and I I'm so proud of each and every one
of you. God bless you and thank you very
much. Have a great weekend.
Thank you, Dr. Wallach. You do the same.
>> Thanks, Doc. Absolutely. So, folks,
you are an empowered individual. You can
make decisions on what you put in your
body and have around your
self, your environment,
to create a healthier lifestyle. And
that is what we are all about in in
empowering you to make those decisions.
You don't have to have a prescription
telling you to do it. You can do it on
your own.
So, we do hope that you got some value
from today's program on what can be done
for some of the most common conditions,
symptoms that are experienced
uh especially in the United States, but
I know they're experienced around the
world. And it does have to do with our
food. It does have to do with nutrient
deficiencies, and there are solutions.
So, get back with your
person that recommended you to watch
this program.
Tell them, "Okay,
what do I need?" And they're going to
help you put together the list
based on Dr. Wallach's recommendations
and help you get on that road to a
better health journey. If there is not
somebody that you are working with or
that referred you to this program,
you may give us a call at 855-949-3377,
and one of our certified holistic health
coaches will be glad to help you as
well.
Now, with me on the screen today and and
there's a couple other coaches. There's
a lot actually a lot of coaches today on
the program. I just want to give a
shout-out to those that are here with
me. We've got Ruth Ellen. She's my
executive production manager who helps
make sure that everything is in place,
keeps us organized. Thank you so much,
Ruth Ellen. We have Marilyn, which
folks, if you're not in the Zoom or if
you are in the Zoom and you are not
looking at that chat, you're not getting
the full benefit of the program where
she is putting dictation into and
repeating the recommendations that Dr.
Wallach is making for the individual,
including the symptoms that were given
um of that individual. Thank you,
Marilyn. We have Albert who's helping to
let people in and also field questions,
bringing them into the program, joining
us from way down south in South Africa,
southeast, west, whichever way you want
to go, it's still very much south of me.
And we have AJ who is
um helping make sure that all the
streams are going,
checking questions,
getting the newsletter out that includes
replays and invitations to our program,
so make sure that you go to our website,
dailywithdoc.com,
sign up for that email list, and get
your name on that so that you also can
receive our emails that then give you an
easy way to find programs
for the past and also those coming up
and follow us on TikTok.
So, for those of you that are on TikTok
and Snapchat and Rumble and YouTube and
Facebook, please follow us.
No matter where you're at, there is a
way that you can you can follow us, you
can send us some likes, some loves, some
hearts, uh subscribe, whatever that
platform allows you to do, and share.
Share this program with others because
be
It's because of a program like this
that I found Dr. Wallach's solutions
that have allowed me to be able to
reclaim life, enjoy life, and not dread
getting older.
That can be for everybody.
And maintain good health, too. So, it's
not all about helping the sick,
but it's also about keeping the healthy
healthy. My name is Becca Dukes. Thank
you so much for joining us here. If you
would like to learn more about Dr.
Wallach's
philosophy
or learn about how to become a certified
holistic health coach yourself,
go to coach with doc. That's coach, c o
a c h,
w i t h d o c dot com, and get more
information and sign up. Enroll in the
certified holistic health coach course
offered by the Institute of Holistic
Health, and there is a discount code, a
promo code. We love those promo codes.
Save 50. Save is all capitals and then 5
0. So, until next time, have a fabulous
weekend, and we will see you.
Be empowered. Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, [music] treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. [music]
We are honored to have a founding father
of the science of epigenetics guiding us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain optimal health. Dr. Joel
Wallach.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of [music] your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. [music] We are
honored to have a founding father of the
science of epigenetics guiding us with
the best options to obtain or maintain
optimal health, Dr. Joel Wallach.
[music]
>> [music]